100 هجوم الروسيه خلال 24 ساعه تم احباطها
في منطقه دنيتك وفق الرئيس الاوكراني
فولودو ميرسي
الجبهه الواقعه جنوب شرقي البلاد باتت
الاكثر اشتعالا بعد الانسحاب الاخير
للقوات الروسيه من خمسون تحركات واسعه
ونشطه للقوات الروسيه شملت قصه مصنع
لمحركات طائرات بدون طيار في مقاطعه
زابوريجيا وتدمير عده منشات لصناعه
الصواريخ ومستودعات للاسلحه الغربيه في
المقاطعه وفق وزاره الدفاع الروسيه من
جهتها قصفت القوات الاوكرانيه احياء على
اطراف دنياتك واخرى واقعه في وسطها بعدد
غير معلوم من القذائف بحسب روايه السلطات
الانفصاليه وفي محور كوبيانسك على اطراف
خارقيف ضد الجيش الروسي هجوم الاوكرانيا
باتجاه مدينه
الصواريخ الروسيه مراكز الطاقه وقواعد
عسكريه الاوكرانيه بضربات عاليه الدقه
اكدت موسكو انها حقق اهدافها بنجاح
فكره اقراره هدنه قصيره مع روسيا على
اعتبار انها ستتحول فتره راحه لها
لاستعاده قوتها ورص صفوفها وفق تعبيره
ياتي ذلك وسط اتهامات تسوقها سلطات
لوجانسك الانفصاليه للجيش الاوكراني لضم
اعداد من المرتزقه لوحداته او ممن سموهم
بجنود الحرب